if you talk to an artist
and say why do you paint why do you
dance
they don't understand the question
the answer they give is I can't not
right it's there's compulsion and not
all ideas uh have compulsion you know
they don't feed our souls and you know I
think for for probably shared by a lot
of people in this room you know the
question is is what ideas should we be
stubborn with and what ideas should we
know when to quit and I think it's often
often a debate like you have to know
when to quit and you should never quit
and I think the answer is if you can't
stop thinking about it if the idea has
so much Soul at the old it it just
compels you those are the ones that we
never quit we're the other ones sure you
you can sort of figure out a time to
walk away and that is what this became
for me
um uh it was something I couldn't not do
um and when you have that kind of
belief in something desperate belief and
people have it in their families they
have it in their faith they have
Desperate belief in something
um the the criticism
um becomes part of the fun
frankly
um are you I mean the story you're
you're told you're talking about is true
it happened in the early days when I was
talking about start with Y I was on a
stage talking to a fairly large group of
entrepreneurs and business owners and um
the very first it wasn't a question the
very first statement made when we went
to q a a guy just with the microphone
said
um uh I think you're naive
um I don't think you're you've never run
a multi-billion dollar company
I think your ideas are uh useless in the
real world and I don't think it'll ever
work
um and my answer was so don't do it
next question like and and it's not
because I'm I'm was being difficult it's
because I never saw my job
to convince people because I don't think
I'm right
and I don't think that I have answers I
think I have a point of view that's all
and so I'm simply sharing my point of
view and if you don't share my point of
view I'm totally fine with that you know
if you want to run your business your
way you run it your way I just think
business could run this way
um and so I never took it personally
quite frankly when when I got comments
like that or when they questioned my my
credentials or anything like that